imagine pulling a super sick knife in CS
go oh guys
now imagine that shroud pulls the exact
same knife at the exact same time
really that's what happened to famed
skin degenerate anomaly back in 2018. he
and shroud were both opening cases while
streaming and both pulled phase four
Talent dopplers trout being shroud
decided to sign his and put it up on the
Steam Market for an easy sale so
naturally anomaly did the same and tried
to pass off his knife as shrouds open
advice shroud it didn't work of course
and shroud eventually caught on and kept
undercutting anomaly before opening the
exact same knife again but it was epic
and ridiculous and anomaly got a killer
story out of it look I can't believe
what the are the odds